elle vous faire avec un paul bolland
essayiste et gamal à abina cofondateur
du mouvement des droits civiques mon
soir messieurs et merci d'être avec nous
ce soir gamme alabina vous êtes pour les
statistiques ethniques expliquez-nous
leur utilité à vos yeux et ce qu'elle
permettrait de démontrer
je suis pour évidemment j'ai eu
l'occasion d'ailleurs une dizaine
d'années d'en discuter avec des
responsables de l'ined
je suis pour simplement parce que ça
permettrait de mettre la socatur des
réalités qui existent aujourd'hui en ce
pays je vous remercie de m'inviter
d'ailleurs parce que j'ai vu pas mal de
débats dans les médias où la plupart des
gens qui en parlent sont des gens qui ne
sont pas j'utilisais termes très forts
racisées donc des gens qui ne sont pas
ciblés par ces questions de racisme de
structurel de racisme systémique comme
les nuls à lons et donc oui chipon parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui en france
on a un problème des preuves depuis 45
ans à peu près il n'y a pas eu de la
question du racisme en france etc évoqué
de façon très superficielle aller look
et de façon très très limité on dit
toujours il faut condamner ce n'est pas
bien mais par contre il ne faut pas
prendre action coercitive alors que des
lois existent qui sont peu appliquées et
surtout il faut surtout pas identifié la
problématique à savoir l'exclusion du
parti la population non négligeable
entre président forçant l'exclusion de
tous les systèmes d'intégration comme
les appelle donc cinq ans par l'école
évidemment et des écoles sectorisé ça
commence aussi par les grandes écoles on
n'y a pas droit
ça se poursuit avec évidemment la
présence dans les médias même si
maintenant il ya un petit effort qui est
fait et ça se conclut clairement pas la
question des contrôles par exemple
excessif pour patiès la question des
violences policières la question de
l'exclusion au plus système
d'intégration économique puisqu'on est
massivement frappé par un chômage 40% en
banlieue en gros ces statistiques
ethniques permettrait de mettre la faute
sur les difficultés que rencontrent les
gens issus de l'immigration
deux trois quatre générations par
rapport à un système qui malheureusement
ne dit pas son nom qui est un système
d'exclusion et de privilèges pourquoi
est ce que la france a montré un tel
aresti sentent face à ces statistiques
ethniques on évoque une forme de
tradition à risque de communautarisme
aussi pourquoi est ce que vous vous n'y
est pas favorable je n'y suis pas
favorable parce qu'effectivement la
tradition française dans sa pure lignée
républicaine universel consacré bien des
individus comme français comme
appartenant tous et toutes à la
communauté nationale
et on ne voit pas nécessairement
différentes catégories comme les ok
monsieur je pense précisément qu'il n'y
a qu'une seule catégorie c les français
est allé faire des statistiques
ethniques pour aller expliquer à des
guadeloupéens à des réunionnais à tous
les habitants des dom tom qui sont
français tout autant que des
bourguignons ou des picards qu'ils sont
différents ou se retrouver dans une
colonne différents dans des analyses
statistiques me parer à tout le moins
inutile et plus encore dangereux et
lorsqu'on voit aux états unis d'amérique
par exemple la façon dont les
statistiques ethniques sont exploitées
on s'aperçoit bien que les tensions
interethniques aux états unis d'amérique
sont extrêmement fortes qu'elles
existent depuis la ségrégation raciale
etc etc aujourd'hui ces statistiques
ethniques et bien ne font rien de bon
donc je ne crois pas à cela je pense que
notre salut en france réside dans notre
concorde tricolore dans notre union
autour de nos valeurs
et lorsque l'on à nos amis de toutes les
couleurs peu importe la couleur je ne
pense qu'il n'y a pas vraiment lieu de
reconnaître des races ou des ethnies
c'est ça me paraît être un recul en
arrière totalement abyssal en fait moi
je
je ne connais pas les races je ne
connais qu'une communauté nationale et
je ne commence pas à faire la différence
dans l'axé
selon votre couleur de peau ou je ne
sais quoi si vous voulez sinon le début
de ce type de choses là peut nous
conduire à des extrémités extrêmement
dangereuse
à commencer par des segmentations des
compartimentation demain qu'est ce qu'on
va faire on va compter le nombre de gays
dans une ville le nombre de bouddhistes
le nombre n'est pas très bien compris
moi donc moi je ne connais ni les gays
ni les bouddhistes ni les noirs ni les
valeurs ni des jaunes je connais les
français je connais l'humanité et je
pense qu'on devrait tous obtenir là pour
faire société tant d'égards à l'avenir à
l'argument du risque de communautarisme
moi j'entends l'argument qui est
symptomatique c'est qu'il ya un problème
il ya cancer qui existe un cancer qui
est violent un cancer qui ronge la
société qui exclut des gens c'est
pourquoi les gens très concret par un
monsieur que j'ai souvent écouté
d'ailleurs monsieur là qu'on parle un
petit peu monsieur l'a fait une grande
école je m'en félicite moi mon ex femme
à femme écolo si elle a fait l'essec à
l'insulter excuse-moi sud de cause c'est
pas l'essec vous êtes dans une des big
man vous avez la chance de temps une
grande grande société internationale
consulting vous avez la chance d'être
dans ce qu'on appelle une élite
intellectuelle
savais que j'étais les écoles les
grandes écoles par les élites
intellectuelles et se trouve que l'on
sait qu'un décor à part les fils
d'ambassadeur il n'y a absolument aucune
représentation déficit je suis
évidemment culteurs monsieur je suis
fils des grilles je tombe très bien
justement vous êtes donc six
agriculteurs aux a fait une liste
d'immigration vous oubliez les arabes
sur la majorité je me rappelle de la
minorité
donc pour tout vous expliquer c'est pas
parce que vous êtes fils d'agriculteur
que vous allez être racisées vous avez
écrit pour des raisons raciales
je vous donne un exemple très concret on
parle de vécu que vous n'avez pas
forcément tu vous n'êtes pas confrontés
à ces réalités
quand je cherche un appartement à paris
je ne trouverai jamais pour ça la vie
simple et bonne raison c'est que
l'appartement à paris n'est pas apte ne
s'adresse pas à autre chose qu'à les
hors pair sûr que quand on est maghrébin
africain ou noir il y a des fiches qui
sont faites et j'ai eu l'information de
source sûre parce que j'ai été le témoin
de sa des fiches qui disent avec des
petits points très discret ne prenons
pas de noirs nous prenons pas la
ramasser des réalités sur les grandes
écoles nous avons grandi comme sait très
bien que l'immigration est totalement
absente
il ya effectivement des fils de pauvre
comme vous qui ont pu accéder aux
grandes écoles mais vous confondez la
question j'ai thalassa vous comprenez la
question sociale qui existe est une
exclusive et la question raciale qui est
encore plus d'excusés parce qu'on a deux
exclusions possible le avant l'exclusion
par le social qui est parfaite on est
fils de deux ouvriers et des petits fils
de paysan donc le che pas de concurrence
mais il ya une question que vous ne
connaissez pas c'est la question raciale
quand vous arrivez vous appelez le map
mohamed et que vous présenter un cv dans
une entreprise vous avez quasiment
aucune chance d'être reçus j'ai envoyé
130 cv à qualifications égales avec un
copain qui s'appelait maxime il a été
reçu immédiatement ou trois entretiens
je n'ai même pas eu la chance d'avoir
une réponse dans l'entretien c'est des
réalités que vous ne connaissez pas
puisque répondre tu sophie vous dites
vous ça va être des 6 et le débat ça va
être américain ce qui est totalement
faux on l'appelle tous la même histoire
mais vous dit pas quelles solutions
apporter à des gens qui sont exclues de
façon radicale depuis 40 ans ça fait 40
ans que ça dure mais j'ai 53 ans je vous
garantis que j'ai toujours connu
exclusion pour des raisons simples le
nom la tête
la zone géographique alors monsieur
ouais non seulement je trouve assez
symptomatique elle c'est intéressant
votre argumentaire pour répondre à mes
amis à mes explications c'est que
finalement vous fait que sont beaucoup
de personnes qui sont dans la logique
intersectionnelle c'est à dire que vous
ramenez votre contradicteur à sa
condition
vous avez moi je me suis pas renseigné
sur vous avant cet entretien et vous
avez obligé de me ramener à mon
curriculum vitæ à mes origines je ne
sais quoi alors moi je vous parlais
d'idées et c'est assez symptomatique
finalement de cette époque de la
transparence où finalement on déshabille
l'interlocuteur parce qu'on n'a pas
d'idée et je trouve ça assez dramatique
parenthèses cette parenthèse étant
terminée et je ne vous ferai pas
l'affront de m'intéresser à ce qu'il ya
dans votre placard ou ce que votre vie
puisque c'est pas mon genre je vais vous
répondre sur le fond
moi effectivement dans ce que j'observe
de ce pays dans ce que j'ai observé
effectivement vous parliez des grandes
écoles
lorsque j'ai observé les grandes écoles
lorsque j'ai travaillé ces je peux vous
garantir et j'ai pas content et parce
que c'est pas j'ai pas ce tic si vous
voulez de prendre mon stylo et puis dire
tiens combien ya deux noirs combien yade
a rappelé combien il ya de blanc non non
moi je ne m'intéresse pas je ne vois j
les gens qui peuvent être des ennemis
des contradicteurs des personnes qui
pensent différemment de moi comme moi
mais en tout cas tant que toutes ces
personnes-là s'accordent si vous voulez
sur liberté égalité fraternité
tant que ces personnes ne comporte
décemment d'alexis wismes ce sont mes
frères et soeurs voilà c'est très très
très simple ma logique et je trouve la
vôtre compliqué et c'est une
complication que je trouve un petit peu
si vous voulez suspecte vous aimeriez
que c'est aboutissent sur quelle mesure
des jeux va tomber ce qui était d'abord
il parle complexité dans mes propos qui
va essayer de quantifier comme étant les
propos pro américain je sais quoi parce
qu'il a dit ce qu'on très très entier
est l'anti qui me dérange pas du tout
moi je suis pas je ne suis pas pro
américain mais par contre il ne répond
pas sur le fond j'ai pris un exemple
avec cas d'école j'ai cliquer sur un cas
d'école j'ai partagé par les deux mon ex
femme
vous ne comptez pas évidemment les
couleurs puisque vous n'êtes pas
intéressé par cette problématique ce
n'est pas un problème pour nous nous y
comptons j'étais dans sa classe était la
seule maghrébine pauvres il ya 2-3 deux
fils d'ambassadeur maroga mais sinon les
tpo ça c'est des réalités que vous ne
voyez pas parce qu'évidemment comme
disait derrida la question des étrangers
est une question qui n'intéressent que
des étrangers
quand j'ai dit à des gens quand
j'entends toujours des débats sur la
question du racisme
tout le monde parle de racisme sans le
connaître il faut le vivre pour le
connaître c'est comme si vous parliez du
cancer sans la voir traverser on peut
actualiser vécu bien évidemment je suis
artiste donc j'ai pas tomber
cinq n'ont jamais ce titre est très
largement parlé de derrida je suis
artiste donc c'est vous qui étaient
trois vous êtes entretien des clichés de
novandie qui connaissent déjà
je suis pour à venir les bourdes et
ethniques pardon
nous allons rire et quelles qu'elles
aboutissent quelle solution est ce
qu'elle pourrait entraîner pour mettre
un terme à certaines situations vous
décrivez vous savez moi je t'explique je
parle là corps malade
aujourd'hui la france attaquera malade
parce qu elle ne revoit pas son passé
quand l'allemagne a été d nazifié en 45
les allemands étaient malades du racisme
structurel d'état c'était ma psy il a
comparé par l'allemagne et la france n'y
a quand même eu 40 millions de
pétainistes qui avait des idées assez
sombre et ensuite il à la guerre
d'algérie qui a laissé des traces jura
dans l'histoire et qui a laissé encore
ce corps malade quand series et les
esprits aujourd'hui avec la syrie la
dentelle tout un tas de problèmes qui se
posent en banlieue on a le sentiment
effectivement que l'immigré
particulièrement de nord africains que
vous nommez pas est un danger pour la
france et les statistiques ethniques
permettrait de mettre à l'africa sur
deux choses si on veut soigner un cancer
il faut identifier le mal savoir où est
le mal et se trouvait la source pour
arriver avec les statistiques on pouvait
comprendre pourquoi est ce que les gens
sont exclus du logement
quelle est la proportion exclusion et
pour quel motif le disque lancement
henri comte parents que par est une
ville de plus en plus européenne est de
moins en moins chères européenne ans en
europe et blanc du terme est de moins en
moins lié à l'immigration parce qu'ils
sont en train de nettoyer la capitale et
quand je tombe nettoyage parle de
nettoyage ethnique le terme est très
fort mais c'est un fait par l'argent le
mot de la fin malheureusement parce que
le temps file comment est-ce qu'on
identifie le mal dont parle à l'enfant
gamala abina sans avoir recours aux
statistiques ethniques
on met d'abord il faudrait se mettent
d'accord - monsieur avec ce qu'est le
mal ne l'ont pas probablement pas la
même définition
moi ma ma vision des choses ma vision de
la chose et là le meilleur affront qu'on
puisse faire au racisme finalement ce
n'est pas de le réhabiliter en
classifiant les gens c'est au contraire
d'effacer cette notion que je trouve
aujourd'hui un peu passé que la notion
de race qui est une notion que je raise
laisserai bien au 18e ou 19e siècle pour
une notion de concorde tricolore
d'absolu et une notion aussi de de
conquête de soi même par la méritocratie
par l'engagement dans ces projets et moi
si vous voulez
je pense personnellement que le meilleur
moyen d'accéder à un appartement à un
travail et si on considère que c'est ça
le sens de la vie mais on peut donner
tout un tas de sens à notre existence
c'est plutôt et bien le travail les
valeurs le civisme et que c'est par là
qu'on s'en sortira collectivement merci
à tous les deux messieurs d'avoir
participé à cet échange père roland
essayiste gamal a admis dahabi n'a
pardon cofondateur du mouvement des
droits civiques merci à tous les deux et
à très bientôt sur rt francs faire